Now, there are many, many different forms of that.
So if we think about the parties, an example I ran into recently.
Involved the board of directors that had chosen a new CEO.
A very private process. They provisionally chose a new CEO,...
...but the deal depended on the compensation package.
So, the board members looked around and said,...
..."Who do we have that's got lots of negotiating experience..."
"...and really has the interest of the company at heart?"
And they focused on the inside general council.
Great experience, very ethical and so...
...the board tasked the general council to go negotiate the compensation package with the CEO candidate.
Now, that negotiation did not go well at all and the question is "Why?"
Well if you think about it, there were a couple of big problems with the setup.
On the other side of the table was a really...
...very well prepared CEO candidate with good advice.
But most importantly as the negotiation progressed, the inside general council...
...realized that at the conclusion of this negotiation, which would almost certainly happen,...
...the CEO candidate would be his boss and so as your first act...
...to grind down your new boss' compensation, it's probably a bad situation.
Now, that was not a problem with tactics or deal design,...
...that's a problem with the wrong party there.
The board should've chosen somebody without that kind of conflict...
...and the wrong agent make is frequently an issue of this kind.